qui ne changent pas en tout cas c'est le
nombre de personnes qui arrivent des
centaines de personnes des centaines de
milliers de personnes qui arrivent tous
les jours et ça fait plus de ça fait
deux semaines et demi que je suis ici
que je parle avec eux et en tout cas la
constante c'est que ce sont des gens qui
n'ont pas envie d'être ici qu'ils
n'avaient pas envie de fuir leur pays et
qui surtout espère pouvoir y rentrer et
retourner le plus rapidement possible
alors les gens que vous voyez peut-être
derrière moi arrivées se sont dans leur
grande majorité des femmes des enfants
il ya énormément d'enfants ici des
personnes âgées elles sont toutes
extrêmement reconnaissante de l'accueil
qui leur est fait ici c'est un accueil
évidemment d'urgence et un accueil un
peu basique si vous regardez ici autour
de moi il ya des ong qui peuvent leur
donner un peu de nourriture chaude et
boissons chaudes et couvertures quelques
peluches pour les enfants un peu de
nourriture pour les animaux de compagnie
qui ont été apportées donc les
ukrainiens les réfugiés venus d'ukraine
sont reconnaissantes cet accueil mais
tous ceux à qui je parle espère surtout
qu'ils pourront bientôt rentrer chez eux
bonjour emmanuel effectivement vous
lisiez à l'instant et on voit d'ailleurs
vous quelques-unes des tentes installées
pour accueillir dans la mesure du
possible au mieux cesser ces exilés
ukrainien comment s'organise la pologne
et bien écoutez et s'organise tant bien
que mal la pologne la pologne a déjà
accueilli plus de 1,7 million de
réfugiés certains jours c'était plus de
cent mille personnes qui arrivaient tous
les jours dans la ville à ses proches de
chez michel il ya eu un pic à 50 mille
personnes par jour sachant que c'est
exactement le nombre d'habitants de
cette ville vous imaginez le poids de
cette crise humanitaire sur les
municipalités sur les régions pourtant
elles ont organisé des centres
d'hébergement d'accueil notamment des
écoles qui ont été réquisitionnés les
habitants aussi les polonais notamment
des régions frontalières héberge
également des ukrainiens et dans la
capitale varsovie il ya déjà plus de 10%
de ses 1,7 million de réfugiés si bien
que le maire de varsovie tout comme les
autorités polonaises ont également
appelé la communauté internationale à
soutenir la pologne la pologne a
débloqué une enveloppe de 1 vient hull 6
milliards d'euros pour tenter de gérer
cette crise humanitaire sauf que cette
crise humanitaire et bien on en voit
sans doute que le début il ya beaucoup
d'interrogations sur les semaines sur
les mois à venir quant à la gestion
cette crise